marvel movies are for kids right
well based on the jump scares and scary
imagery doctor strange 2 is apparently
for making kids cry here are all the
things only adults noticed in the
surprisingly frightening doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness
the one thing that was abundantly clear
about america chavez and doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness was that
she had seen a lot having traveled
across the multiverse she had visited 72
universes before landing on earth 616
however there was one superhero she had
failed to encounter or even know
anything about during her adventures
spider-man while most people might point
out that it's because of doctor
strange's spell at the end of spider-man
no way home that's not an entirely
correct assumption strange's spell made
everyone forget that peter parker
existed not spidey even happy hogan
confirmed to pete that he knew aunt may
through spider-man at her gravesite
taking into account the three spider-men
that appeared in no way home plus all
the others introduced and into the
spider-verse what are the odds that
america only visited universes without
any spider-themed heroes or variants
no miles morales no miguel o'hara no
spider-gwen
this is starting to smell a whole lot
like a gigantic plot hole
wanda maximoff experienced a
heartbreaking and life-changing moment
when she removed the mind stone from
vision's head which was a vital part of
keeping him alive
then she had to suffer the pain and loss
all over again as thanos reversed time
and destroyed the android once more for
good measure these events can change
someone and in wanda's case they had a
big effect as we all saw in wanda vision
her grieving process was to say the
least ethically questionable if you
won't let us go just let us die
while we cannot condone wanda's actions
or methods her former teammates hardly
made any effort to provide her comfort
during her period of grief
sure everyone experienced their own
losses after thanos snap and had a lot
to deal with but no one attempted to
even be a shoulder to cry on for wanda
even knowing that she'd lost her brother
pietro and then the love of her life in
all likelihood wanda might have pushed
them away but at least she would have
known they cared about her ultimately
she was alone and this led her to the
dark hold and the path of trying to
create a family to deal with her trauma
with friends like the avengers who needs
enemies right
and now
it's time for some good news
undoubtedly one of the hottest cameos of
dr strange in the multiverse of madness
was the appearance of john krasinski as
reed richards aka mr fantastic of earth
838 while social media might have
spoiled the big reveal because film
twitter cannot contain itself with
secrets it was still an exciting moment
as it announced the official arrival of
the fantastic four in the mcu the rest
of marvel's first family didn't show up
but it was more than enough to lay a
solid foundation for the impending film
with the confirmation that the fantastic
four exists within the multiverse it
leaves one major question here why
didn't the earth 616 version of the team
try to stop thanos with the avengers yes
krazynski's mr fantastic was from a
different universe but there must be
other versions of the fantastic four
sprinkled throughout the multiverse are
we meant to believe that reed richards
one of the world's greatest minds didn't
have anything to add and chose to stay
at home in the baxter building while the
rest of earth's heroes battled thanos
evil forces they must have been busy
with something interesting maybe we'll
get some answers in the upcoming movie
fox's x-men series ended quietly with
the release of the new mutants preceded
by the purchase of 20th century fox by
disney but long before that purchase the
canon of the x-men movies had become
hopelessly confusing that timeline has
undergone more revamps and reimaginings
than extreme makeover home edition
without a doubt the mcu will try to
remedy this situation with the children
of the atom becoming a part of the
greater marvel universe and the first
step was introducing the earth 838
version of patrick stewart's professor
charles xavier in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness while stewart's
professor x was from fox's ex-verse
there are a few hints that he may be the
mutant from another popular incarnation
of the x-men when professor x appeared
in the film he glided onto the screen in
the recognizable yellow hover chair from
x-men the animated series additionally
he wore a green top to match the
character's design from the cartoon
however the biggest aha moment was when
a hint of the classic theme song from
the animated show played in the
background of course this could be an
homage or merely fan service for long
time supporters of the mutant
superheroes but wouldn't it be a novel
idea if x-men the animated series ends
up being the backstory of the mcu's
x-men with the animated show returning
with the upcoming sequel series x-men 97
on disney plus don't bet against it
the fact that the title of the film
includes multiverse of madness is a good
indication that not everything was meant
to make sense here however there was one
glaring issue that cannot be overlooked
remember spider-man no way home and how
it brought all the peter parkers
together while it was fun to hear mj and
ned call peter and for all of them to
respond at the same time it was evident
that all three peters looked different
and were distinguishable from each other
this is peter parker's peter parker
spider-man spider-man they're bees from
other universes they're here to help
so why do the variants of steven strange
christine palmer and wanda maximoff all
look the same in the multiverse apart
from a different haircut or some
slightly different attire they all
looked identical it was easy to spot who
they were and the shared features made
them instantly recognizable to people
from other universes using this logic
all three of the spider-man should have
looked like tom holland's version of the
character naturally this new logic could
be the result of doctor strange's spells
having adverse effects on the multiverse
but it still seemed peculiar how america
chavez who had been traversing the
universes for some time didn't mention
anything about it
in earth 616 iron man sacrificed himself
to end thanos's reign of terror in dr
strange in the multiverse of madness it
was shown how the illuminati also
brought down the mad titan in their own
universe connecting the dots this points
to one significant conclusion there are
multiple versions of thanos throughout
the multiverse and they're all likely
hungry for power
impossible
as portals have been opened and people
have zipped in and out of the different
universes what are the odds that another
thanos hasn't slipped through the cracks
as well his brother eros aka star fox
was introduced in the post credits scene
of eternals a powerful figure like him
will need a formidable foe and who is
more formidable than his brother the mad
titan a villain as big and monumental as
thanos doesn't just go away quietly
after one rumble it's not outside the
realm of possibility that some version
of him may be laying low and licking his
wounds as he plots his revenge on
earth's mightiest heroes and prepares to
strike once again
previous mcu films have made it clear
that wanda maximoff is a powerful
character you may recall that she
appeared capable of defeating thanos
almost single-handedly however as the
scarlet witch and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness she showed off
just how opie or overpowered if that's
not clear she really was not only did
she wipe out captain carter captain
marvel reed richards and black bolt on
her own but she also wiped out the army
of kamar taj without breaking a sweat
forget about great power and great
responsibility because when someone
holds the potential to get into people's
heads and snap them like their twigs
it's best to put pride aside and call in
the heavy guns for help for some reason
though doctor strange didn't do that he
knew that scarlet witch was heading to
camartage to collect america chavez and
she had already told him her demands
beforehand
yet instead of phoning up the avengers
and asking for some super powered backup
he decided to rely on magic students as
the front line of defense
perhaps strange underestimated his
former colleague but he could have at
least called up jimmy wu and darcy lewis
to find out how much damage the scarlet
witch had caused in westview maybe then
he wouldn't have been so reluctant to
seek out major assistance in the first
place
when doctor strange tried to reason with
scarlet witch about the severe
consequences of messing with the
multiverse she turned at the tables and
pointed out how it was deemed acceptable
when he did the same you break the rules
and become a hero
i do it and i become the enemy
she says it's not fair and she's not
wrong while there was an element of what
about ism in her response she raised a
valid point about strange's double
standards in spider-man no way home wong
warned him about what would happen but
strange didn't heed his warnings
instead he opened the world to possible
new threats because of a request from
spider-man while it was undoubtedly sad
that spidey's true identity was exposed
to the world strange was prepared to
risk the safety of the entire universe
to reverse a single event
surely there were other solutions here
even if it meant that peter parker would
have to hide out for a period of time
until they figured it out yet the first
port of call here was magic the kind
that creates seismic rifts in the
universe while scarlet witch wasn't
right in wanting to sacrifice a person
for her own delusion of personal
happiness neither was strange who was
prepared to risk an entire world for one
person from what we have seen in the mcu
doctor strange has never been what one
would call a people person he can come
across as prickly condescending and
sometimes even cruel this isn't the end
there are other things that can give
your life meaning like wife like you
however he displayed a lot of initial
disrespect to wang in doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness when
approaching the sorcerer supreme there
were certain formalities that needed to
be adhered to such as bowing before him
for strange he didn't do this for the
better part of the film only doing so in
the end
it was surprising to see strange behave
in this way since wong had not only been
a friend but also the person who
assisted him in studying the mystic arts
he had a wealth of knowledge and even
knew important concepts about the
multiverse that strange had no idea
about much like spider-man no way home
strange didn't listen to wong when he
really should have
hopefully his change in demeanor at the
end of multiverse of madness signified
that he would be taking wang and his
position as the sorcerer supreme much
more seriously in the future
out of all the characters from the
previous marvel films and tv shows who
would have put money on an inhuman
showing up in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness lest we forget the
inhumans tv show holds an 11
critical approval rating and a 44
audience score on rotten tomatoes after
all the ridicule and bad press one would
imagine that kevin feige would have sent
the inhumans into the darkest part of
the multiverse never to be seen again
yet ants and mount returned as black
bolt in sam raimi's film this time
however he was kitted out in a comic
book accurate outfit and portrayed as
more of an omega level threat than what
was seen in the series like his comic
book counterpart no one wanted him to
speak a word knowing that a single
whisper could decimate anyone around him
[Music]
equally important here dr strange in the
multiverse of madness proved that there
could be life and a future for the
inhumans in the mcu
not that team necessarily but the
inhumans in general they might have had
a rough time on the abc show but they
could still play an important part in
marvel movies going forward maybe mount
may return as black bolt for a third
time ensuring that vin diesel's
long-standing dream of playing the
silent superhero never happens
[Laughter]
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]